a common image when it comes to beer men
raising mugs of the frothy brew and to
those who say there's nothing less
ladylike than beer well times are
changing Freda Liga strata from debt
malt is living proof that women can brew
too she and her sister Sylvia are two of
the few women in the top ranks at a
German brewery as a president have made
onion and I ever really thought about it
gender is irrelevant I think brewing
beer is the best craft there is I love
our brewery and our beer I grew up here
frederica is the fifth generation of her
family to brew the small traditional
business employs only 30 people and it
doesn't advertise until recently their
beer was made only for regional
consumption but for about two years now
it's been in demand across Germany sales
took off after an online beer tasters
Club crowned tues Nelda brew their beer
of the year this phone's admitted it's a
mid-sized firm it's very important for
us because it's hard to compete with all
the commercial beers on TV the market
pressure just keeps on growing up in my
close-up men dominate the brewing
industry today but that didn't used to
be the case at all
during the Middle Ages brewing was
traditionally a woman's job only the
monks in their monasteries competed with
the ales women made at home hbu
enthroned rubia and women always went
together because the women had to take
care of food and drink beer was included
that's why I didn't in ancient Egypt
among the Babylonians and the Germanic
tribes it was the same come on and
Eden's or mass production of beer only
began with the onset of
industrialization that's when men took
over
but today singular flavorful beers are
back in demand and that's exactly what
Esther a zach has on sale at her store
be allowed in Hamburg her inventory
includes 300 varieties from all over the
world people called the former
interpreter the beer queen because she
always knows just the right variety for
every type of drinker and women come
here looking for a special taste
experience a gourmet experienced men are
usually just thirsty that's why men
aren't really welcome when barleys
angels meet it's an international club
for female connoisseurs of brew with
over 5,000 members izaak founded the
first german branch what does this beer
tell us the group agrees it has a note
of lychee it's lee ji on the list no add
lychee every trace of taste counts beer
isn't unexplored universe the option
what I've always liked drinking beer but
this isn't a typical becks or whatever I
don't like those then I came here and
this was a little like paradise sure
doesn't like guns thali do I think it's
a great idea as a woman you've got so
many drinks to choose from sometimes
you're uncertain about trying beer and
beer hun barleys Angels is a growing
phenomenon in Germany and elsewhere in
the world more and more women now want
to have their say about what brews are
best the islands king men are not
working against men we're just saying
hello there are women here your beer
would improve if you'd asked them what
they like because we make up fifty
percent of the potential market but no
one seems to care about us you're put in
San kunzelman knows about central satish
connivance varley's angels want to
change that and bring women to the fore
when it comes to assessing the best that
beer has to offer
you